we won't get our hands on prey until
next year
but that doesn't mean we haven't learned
more about the powers and weapons we'll
get to use I'm Tony and this is your
space action gamespot news update thanks
to a game informer cover story we've
gotten a bunch of new details about
protagonist Morgan use arsenal weapons
include a stun gun a foam cannon that
can create makeshift platforms and
grenades that suck in enemies like a
vacuum as for Morgan's psychic powers
you'll be able to lift and manipulate
objects or even assume their form to
hide from enemies you can control other
humans and fire away at all sorts of
creatures with kinetic energy blasts and
those are just the powers we know about
right now prey doesn't have a solid
release date yet but it's coming to ps4
Xbox one and PC and 2017 you can expect
plenty more information to trickle out
in the meantime so keep an eye on
gamespot for all the latest and for all
the biggest prey news you're already in
the right place